Hello internet!
You’re watching Mostly Weekly
and I’m intermittently Andrew Heaton.
Interns!
The muse of Hollywood studios who like to
ask:
what if an intern was a hilariously out-of-touch
old dude?
The answer is hijinx.
This summer millions of students across our
great land are working in internships.
How do I know?
Because we asked our Mostly Weekly intern,
Clint,
to do some fact-checking and some work around
the set.
And according to his research, the US has
8 bajillion unpaid interns.
So why do people love unpaid interns?
Because the labor is cheap, if not a bit unreliable.
Fuck!
We're proud of you Clint! you're doing-
Shut up!
Companies want cheap labor
and college students are willing to work for
the experience.
And job seekers are willing to work for free
in order to get a foot in the door at a company
they like.
But many companies are eliminating their unpaid
internship programs altogether.
Why?
Because most unpaid interns are illegal.
In fact, the exact wording says:
“The employer that provides training
derives no immediate advantage from the activities
of the intern;
and on occasion its operations may actually
be impeded.”
So. in other words, you can hire an unpaid
intern,
you just don’t let them do anything helpfoot.
Clint- I think maybe you misspelled “helpful”
in the teleprompter buddy.
No, Clint, don’t be like that!
Why you gotta...
I'll let you come in at ten.
Here's the thing:
I think two consenting adults should be able
to do whatever they want
with or to each other
and that includes internships.
Unpaid interns meet a network of people
you could only meet through the wonderful
world of work!
And finally understand the movie “Office
Space.”
References.
References are an incredibly valuable way
to find work
you can only get by having work experience
in the first place.
Back in the days before unpaid internships,
I used to give my own number as a reference
and pretended to be my own former employer.
Oh ay, Heaton was a great guy.
Eye for detail, all that stuff.
Uh, knows Microsoft suite and... haggis.
All right, that's the bagpipes, got to go
Braveheart to you.
Well my word!
Andy Heaton's a tall drink of water
that never had no drug charges.
Another benefit is work lessons
Without an unpaid internship, where-
uh, hey buddy,
you got your finger on the lens, could you
take, could you move your finger?
You just moved your fingers up, that's not
doing anything,
Okay, I'm just going to work around, uh
Work lessons!
They're important, you can get them from unpaid
internships.
There are also a suspicious number of congressmen
who have unpaid interns
but ALSO voted to increase the minimum wage
but ALSO use unpaid interns.
Hey Clint, don't walk in front of the green
screen.
You're not my dad!
So for them, it’s fine to work for $8 an
hour or zero, but nothing in between.
Hashtag: congresslogic.
Look unpaid internships aren’t ideal,
it’s better to get paid, I know.
But it’s also better than not having any opportunities
at all.
Wanting to ban unpaid internships is like
wanting to ban hot pockets
because we don’t have both hot pockets and
pizza.
And, let’s at least consider things from
the perspective of the employer.
If the government forces an employer to pay
their interns,
what possible incentive do they have to hire
a twenty-something nobody
for eighty-something days?
That’s not even enough time to figure out
how to work the fax machine.
Or in Clint’s case- facts.
I love ya buddy!
Shut up!
Weirdly, working for free can be an advantage
for someone looking to get experience.
But companies face increasing legal scrutiny
to hire them,
which is why we should legalize unpaid-
Hello?
Hey Clint, buddy!
Well, how did you get there?
I... cut the blue wire?